the more sick you had the more children
you had yeah but now
that's why you only had back in the day
you only had sex with one person because
you're gonna have kids with them but now
there's less kids there's more sex
because there's contraception and that's
what the men don't want
so you might say you know what they
might want me because I've not had no
children but you might have no children
but 15 previous partners
and that's the difference
but how would they know that's another
thing that I feel like men talk we not
can see anyway I mean the same way when
you're dating you're vetting a woman
um you're vetting a man I'm vetting a
woman
once you're with them for a while you'll
start seeing even if you never say to me
hours of 15 guys you'll start seeing
little things that will present yourself
like they said let a woman talk she'll
tell on herself yes
definitely but um and and if you if this
is the guy you want don't you want to be
honest like don't you want him to really
know you inside out
I would agree but if you feel that
there's nothing wrong with it it doesn't
matter then you should be sticking to
what you think oh I've been with 20 guys
now do you want me and if you if you
can't say it with your chest maybe you
shouldn't have been with 20 guys I would
agree but the way you know what yeah I
would agree but the way you guys are
placing value on body count it would
like I am my head that would make women
want to lie about it that's what I mean
like that's the women that wouldn't want
to be honest because of the value that's
placed on it well they do lie about it
that's why you're supposed to start from
Young
yeah then you don't have to lie I've had
free yeah and you say it with your chest
no but this is what I'm saying you're
saying that so I'm going back to her
point because she said that a man
wouldn't want a woman with the history
with a long with a long history but I'm
saying because you're placing because
our generation plays in so much value on
it that's what's going to give women the
tendency to lie and your point was women
wouldn't lie because they would want to
be honest with whoever it is but because
your place in Valley it's like a circle
it's like we're going around in circles
no no he's not saying that women
wouldn't lie he's saying like
now you have to live with a secret the
rest of your life that your thought in
your marriage basically yeah right yeah
and so wouldn't you like I don't want to
be with someone there where you thought
you was being honest with well because I
don't necessarily think it's like over
for girls that have a high body count
sorry because I asked guys this question
all the time I say okay um would you
prefer a girl with this many body like a
higher body count but she hasn't slept
with anyone you know
or I say would you rather a girl that
slept with two guys you know there's the
only other guy she slept with
and every guy every guy says hi body
count as long as I don't know him as
long as I don't know him so so girls can
get away with it they just move right
but like the issue is it's internal
because it hurts your ability to pair
bond and so you can't connect with the
guy you're supposed to be with as much
if you've been with like guy after guy
after guy after guy you're exchanging
energies yeah I do get what you mean but
again I feel like another assumption I
thought it is probably the case but
another assumption we're making is that
the older you are the higher your body
count is well it's more likely yeah
you're gonna have had it's just okay if
you're 18 if you're 21 right versus 35
you're going to have had more
Relationships by the time you're 35 and
I know like I know the girls
trust me I see some of my I'm not going
to name names but some of the young this
young girls these days I'm like y'all
are wild and they're they're like
they're younger than me right but
they've definitely been with way more
people than I have but it's just how do
I put it like they can't undo the damage
to themselves
yeah and and there's still some value in
youth so they still have like that that
youth aspect and that's valuable to a
guy
so would you say that someone that's 35
with a lower body count would be seen as
more valuable than someone that's
younger the higher body can't I don't
know ask the guys
um
that's an I'd say it's an equal one only
because someone that's young with a high
body count has youth
someone that's old with a low body count
doesn't have youth but they have body
count so yeah it's a it's a catch-22 but
typically like women at 35 have like the
worst of Both Worlds like I would say
it's an exception that a girl makes it
to 35 and hasn't slept with more than
five people but you could find a girl at
21 that that hasn't done that a lot
easier
yeah
just in like law in general right
there's exceptions like there's a guy in
my show that married a girl in her 30s I
was a virgin like there's exceptions
it's just not the rule
yeah it definitely is I feel like again
it just goes
it it depends highly on what the person
values
in a woman
yeah hey look I'm I this is advice for
you because more so like you're a pretty
girl and more so you'd find someone
a lot easier and better that you'd deem
high value if you was to vet now as
opposed to at 35
I just don't agree with because the
problem with that term left over is I
feel like it's all based on fertility
like you're placing a woman's value on
her ability to have kids
that's my problem well it's because what
does the guy get out of the deal like
why would a guy get married most of the
time it's for kids
yeah I do I do get one but it's just me
personally I'm not saying there's a
problem with men doing that but me
personally I just don't think a woman's
value should be based on her ability to
have children well we can say it
shouldn't but we but it is what it is
right like I don't again I don't enjoy
that you know the older I get the less
value I'm going to have but it is what
it is like I think it's worse to ignore
reality and just hope for the best when
I turn 35. I would say it's definitely
true again like I said like me
personally I wouldn't wait till 35 to be
considering but my problem is I just
don't like I disagree with the term left
over like I I just so I really disagree
with that do you think it's untrue
I wouldn't say it's untrue but I
disagree with it like something so
something could be real like it's real
but I still something could be real like
this is the real life case but I still
disagree okay so so in a way you don't
disagree you agree you just don't like
it
or is it the wording
yeah you can't change yeah
in the Chinese thing that let's
nervousness
I think it was something in the chat
should we make merch with leftover women
yeah
left over it sounds like food like it
just sounds so derogative
leftovers are nice but the thing is
would you want food that everybody else
has picked up yeah right what do you
mean when you want food that everyone
else has picked up you're hungry you see
a plate of food there and everybody's
picked it would you really gonna eat it
the mark
you wouldn't go and eat it because it's
leftovers everybody's been at it and
that leftover food on that plate is the
woman
everybody's picked at it there's nothing
left that all the chicken wings they've
left all the bones left they left all
the gristle everything's there who wants
it
Not Me It's gotta be somebody starving a
hard up right and that's what the women
are going to end up with We're not gonna
say you're gonna be single you're gonna
end up with somebody starving a heart up
who can do no better but eat the
leftovers there's men out there for
women like that
you have a